I've burst into her bathroom with a BB
gun while she was trying to pee
and me and Michael I'm naked I'm weird
unloading on her let me just wait
[Music]
I want
to like blow my wife away
with like a romantic night out what do I
do
you said it what
we'll hear what
[Applause]
I've been to Scotland I went to Isle of
Skye oh that's very close to Ireland oh
my gosh it's like it's so beautiful
there yes it is yeah yeah every time I
think about it yeah that's true and we
were I know oh my gosh well I was there
during summer too so it
goes on all night
I like it when my man gives me a big
heart
kiss
I can't say the answer I want to say
[Applause]
what is something that you love that
everyone else doesn't
penis facials
[Applause]
I mean I know how seriously comic book
nerds take this kind of stuff because I
am one of them really what do you think
about my breast a what
[Applause]
it sounds weird I don't know hold on let
me figure it out
they look great yeah both of them thank
you
have you ever you ever had blood in a
cut in your hand
I yeah I I had my period where I you
know put my hand through it
there's a scene uh where you uh pleasure
yourself how do you approach that kind
of scene that's got to be a strange
thing to shoot on camera how do I
approach it mentally or just
thank you
did you get to do any of the fun stuff
did you get the fire guns of that size
or smaller did you get to do that weapon
and was there a big recoil when you when
you yeah but that's I loved it I loved
feeling that vibration and
stew every day oh man I have to make
coffee before the breakfast is done in
the microwave that's game number one
work out and I have to look at naked
people
so like a fragment portion of it is in
my tongue so it kind of changed the way
I speak a little bit it's still in your
tongue can you see
for oral sex
because I grew up in Albuquerque what
was there any cool places anything that
you liked being there like how'd you
like it oh did you have fun there yeah
go and visit your mother once in a while
what
would you want big boobs or small boobs
medium boost I'd want a good hand full
of boobs are your are your hand showing
how far out your boobs would come there
it's just a good like just cupping
nicely besides your face what body part
do you look at the most in the mirror
[Applause]
they don't want to look at it
but
the thing
of your fear what are you afraid of well
I was gonna go with flying but I think
I'll go with um girls over 12.
besides making love showering or
swimming what is something else you've
enjoyed doing naked watch TV
you watch TV naked
is that weird
it definitely affects my personal life
sure you know my personal life is pretty
much non-existent
which is not good
um not for the long run not for me not
for her it's not it's not
[Applause]
dude what kind of food that's squirty
yeah you know like cream and berries and
such berries who squirts berries
trained athletes oh really
[Laughter]
but it's Valentine's Day so you can
square whatever you want no you can't
no you can cream berries no anything
goes no no no
[Laughter]
it's hot why do I say
[Applause]
thank you
we hung out all night because I think
most girls meet Justin and be like ah
and be a bit pathetic but like I made
him and just was like hey what's up he's
quite nervous
yes because I was holding his balls
the the reward for me is all in the work
and the reward for me is all and just it
being something that moves you that's
what's most important to me
um
what are you looking at I specifically
you've either have plastic surgery or a
makeover because you look really hot
today oh you're so annoying you're so
obnoxious you wonder why everybody hates
you
wow I specifically covered up so you
couldn't look at me and undress me with
your molester eyes
Ellen name three things you say to a
cute baby oh
are you wet
I really often I often I dream about the
end of the world
that's a say extreme
so what about when I dream about sex
that's a sex dream
okay so what about uh
sex dream yeah of course if a man zipper
breaks a church what might he use to
cover it up a child
wow
whoa what a child
was locked up not a good answer not a
good answer
name three things that get you in
trouble with your spouse
the internet
[Applause]
I don't even know what I'm gonna say
before I say it it just flies out of my
mouth is that how does that work what
happens when you find yourself in a
situation where sincerity is Paramount
what the way you're looking at me makes
me want to cover up my vagina
[Applause]
Madam if I had rubber gloves I'd do it
for you
I have a chest and I have what they call
pecs you don't put your hand on that
okay put your hand on that what are you
feeling I feel abreast
the way that I met Simon was they asked
me to be a guest judge Focus Conan to be
um
we've been discussing Christmas presents
to get from our parents right it's true
and he said that he wanted to get his
mum as many cats as he could
because because she like cats right so
21 I said think how many cats you can
get
favorite body
man
arms that can pick me up
[Applause]
what is
that wasn't me that said that that was a
parasites inside me that said that
nothing where's the rest of your outfit
you have it what's up you look nice
as you look at that this is just for you
but then they told me you were gay so
I I assure you this is an area in which
I'm confident I am not bluffing
I will take care of you I will make you
see multi-colored I'll make you forget
your own name it'll be wonderful
no you have a nice Valentine's Day first
Valentine's Day married
um yeah I I kind of dropped the ball
Craig
[Music]
I don't think anyone would mind
just pick it up keep going
[Music]